all right stores and democrat-run cities
doing everything they can to combat
raging retail theft we're all familiar
with the images of toothpaste and every
other day items locked up behind plastic
barriers and now shops are resorting to
another method to thwart shoplifters
facial recognition technology some say
it's pretty effective but city council
members in New York are calling for a
ban on the tech due to concerns of
racial profiling one grocery store owner
is firing back
the city refuses to arrest thieves so
here the retailers want to use
technology the same one we used in the
old Alternatives we used polaroid
pictures you could catch a thief take
Polaroid picture and if that person
comes in again you stop him or her but
New York City wants to make that illegal
on one hand we they do not want to
arrest the thieves and on the other hand
they don't want to give retailers uh the
ability to fight back it's absolutely
out of control and again it's not
conservative or liberal this is
literally insane
and put the outrageous scenes from
America's crime crisis they don't stop
there police are investigating after an
unruly mob of teens was caught on camera
ransacking McDonald's in Los Angeles
with one looter even walking off with
the cash register
uh you know judge every week it seems
like you can't take another further step
towards insanity and yet we do what do
you think about this move of embracing
facial recognition I love it the guy is
absolutely right the government is not
fulfilling its role which is the
protection of its citizens it's not only
assault it's protecting their business
they pay taxes they're entitled to some
kind of protection but the police don't
either have the numbers or they're being
told to stand down or they're walking
well I don't know I'm not here to
criticize the police but you can't deny
uh a business from identifying who's
stealing and saying you can't come in
again they can as long as it's not
racial profiling as long as they keep
good files but I you know the thing that
I don't understand we've talked about
this before in the five you've got 327
repeat offenders that are apparently
responsible for
um thirty percent thirty percent of the
22 000 thefts why doesn't somebody just
lock their butts up and jail and call it
a day give everyone a free couple of
weeks to like go and buy things that
aren't locked up that you need a torch
or you got to beg a clerk to let you uh
access a razor blade so I did the math
on that that's 7 000 of these shoplifts
uh incidents is being done Kennedy by
327 people that's 21 each so they're
essentially going into these places
every other week and robbing one of
these convenience stores these drug
stores these grocery stores yeah and and
we've all seen it I saw it at my CVS it
happened today at the restaurant here in
the Breezeway guy ran in started yelling
at everybody started taking food and it
scares people you don't want to be the
one who intervenes you don't know if
that person has a weapon and God forbid
you defend yourself you don't want to be
the person who was charged but it's like
I have the same problem here that I do
advertising gun-free zones in places
like playgrounds and movie theaters
you're just telling people like hey no
one here is armed they can't protect
themselves and the stores that Telegraph
you know we're not going to arrest
people we're not going to challenge them
so why would anyone change their
behavior if you can hit it and quit it
and go back out and sell everything and
buy illegal drugs which would probably
be legal at this point the system is not
going to change and it certainly in
places like New York LA and San
Francisco and Chicago and other cities
it is on these DA's are on the side of
the criminals and if you want to have a
civil society you're host Tyrese there's
one other element to this I don't know
if you saw the story of this guy in New
York that took a blowtorch to some of
these plastic he literally took a blow
towards you're going to love the
criminal creativity but you know what I
noticed in that in that photo in that
video of what happened in New York he's
wearing a surgical covered mask facial
recognition technology is great but we
are still embracing the idea that you
can come in like a bandit masked into a
store well forget well you know what and
that's the thing that he could have been
using that type of intelligence to be
bettering himself but there's a great
new business it's called free merch the
the numbers that you're talking about
that 30 they're getting better they're
enlisting people they have a great
business now they go rob a store and
then they go sell the goods on eBay or
they post it on their Facebooks they're
not even shy or Brash I'm surprised he
was wearing a mask maybe he was robbing
in somebody else's territory that's why
he was wearing a mask because he
certainly wasn't wearing a mask to hide
his identity because usually then they
go post it and throw their signs up onto
the Facebook and here's the idiocy of
this racial profiling was something
that's designed to recognize the
criminal's face so if the criminal let's
say is light-skinned with tattoos and I
choose to go and break into CVS for some
toothpaste
and my face shows up on the wall I can't
say that's racist so like no that's your
picture of you being a criminal in our
store please don't come back exactly so
if there's six other guys who look like
me good luck finding them
over here but if you but if you find
them and you put them up next to me it's
not profiling it's very good detective
work by your team's security so Jessica
on this final Point whether or not it's
these 327 repeat offenders or it's these
kids honestly these mobs the kids there
does seem to be in our estimation an
obvious implication here there's no fear
of being caught they're just flat out
emboldened yeah well it seems like it
especially in cities where if you don't
hit the thousand dollar threshold or
whatever it is they can't legally take
you in for that anyway or it's at the
Lululemon where they won't even let the
security guards go after people and I
understand and the CEO spoke out about
it that it was actually for the safety
of his employees because he's nervous
that people were going to be attacked
someone could be carrying a gun could
have a knife Etc it's just incredibly
depressing and I do think to the judge's
point
you know there are two options in front
of people who are running these cities
you either allow the businesses to do
what they think they need to do to
protect their businesses and make sure
frankly that they can stay here we need
the tax revenue right we all know that
real estate taxes are going to Skyrocket
very very soon if we continue to lose
businesses at this level or you give
people the security the police support
whatever it is that they need to ensure
that they can protect their merchandise
and
you know keep good records with the
racial profiling stuff and hopefully we
can avoid it as especially in these kind
of you know multi-racial metropolises it
everyone is going in everywhere which is
one of the beauties of these cities and
hopefully it wouldn't be used against a
particular question one thing
do you know that the guy with the
blowtorch took 448 dollars worth of skin
care products yeah is he going out on a
hot maybe he had a rash from
this is ready to get a blowtorch
propane bottles I didn't know they had
welding classes still hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else